alors qu'anne hidalgo s'est fait
éliminer de la course présidentielle
anne hidalgo 1,9 pour cent il semblerait
qu'elle ait déjà du pain sur la planche
avec la ville de paris et les
revendications de ces naturiste c'est
bien qu'il y ait une zone du disque vers
paris mais c'est pas assez la petite
clairière du bois non faudrait plus bien
plus en effet non content d'avoir
seulement une partie du bois de
vincennes pour être le cul cul à l'air à
côté des joggeurs et naturistes vole
désormais plus d espace dédié pour faire
encore plus de trucs à oilpé on organise
un grand pique nique naturiste y aura un
cours de fitness un cours de yoga une
demande qui crée le débat alors les
soutenez vous
c'est un cours de fitness
déconner tu es comme ça ton condé
fêtaient ses toiles nées dans le hub de
l'aude
si on les connaît on vraiment envie de
faire des efforts mais sans déconner et
non mais franchement arrêtez quoi sont
déjà sept mille cinq cents mètres carrés
alors ça suffit pas dans l'univers des
anciens naturiste c'est une insulte
faite au naturel
on leur donne une petite parcelle comme
ci comme ça tu crois vraiment je voulais
voir j'ai envie de voir des délits comme
ça vous savez mon rêve moi on ouvre le
bois de boulogne vous connaissez bagages
beaucoup
n'ont calmé ou s'il vous plaît mais
qu'est ce tu veux toi bagatelle il ya
des ponts qui se baladent et bien on
mettrait les naturistes là moi j'ai ramé
plaisir au milieu des ponts se
promettant que bell veut voir ta tata où
est maman c'est mon rêve voilà on ouvre
paris en nature et en valeur probante
bertrand ta table et du naturisme toi
n'ont jamais de naturisme moi me par
contre la belgique ne comment dire ça
absolument pas interdit il faut savoir
que la loi belge nathalie dit absolument
pas le naturisme est chez nous il ya en
numérique en écolo qui militent qui est
naturiste et qu'il me dit justement pour
la chose et il a créé une manifestation
le cyclo nudiste à quoi tient lieu
chaque année toute une matinée s'achève
et l'onu
après la scène mon frère je peux te dire
avec la conspiration étouffé
retard est un peu chez ce que c'est je
sais ce que c'est je connais très bien
les annuler oui les baruya pas il n'y a
pas d'autres combats un petit peu plus
important en ce moment que de se battre
pour avoir un
pardon mais quand tu vas faire un pique
nique avec en famille on n'a pas envie
de tomber sur les résineux de changy
shell tutoriels et cd de gênes ou non
mais je veux dire ça suffit cette île
syndrome et scarlett c'est déjà assez
bien pour pouvoir se mettre pour les
boulistes
c'est surtout que le bois de boulogne il
déborde s'est passé c'est bon
et les blindés
roulotte basse et la partie
fou ne fermerait pas ce que ces piétons
à partir de 17h30 c'est il ya plein de
trucs
c'est vrai comme si souvent là-bas si tu
trouves une branche d'arbre sega ce soit
dimanche c'est vrai il a il demande un
élan second espace au boulot c'est trop
un second espace ailleurs dans un ses
dents affilées privé pourquoi pas si
vous voulez y aller mais là ils veulent
c c'est toujours pareil ces gens ils
veulent y aller en transport ils veulent
s'asseoir à côté eloignez-vous un peu le
bois de boulogne déborde il a déjà fait
du naturisme est
sous l'eau d'entre nous
c'est vrai c'est vrai les gars moi j'en
étais à djerba c'est vrai je tenais en
babouches à l'eau à bien gouverner à
elle doit bien vous arrête on regarde
pas et que c'est lui qui voulait parler
noms qui n'ont moi j'ai aucune envie de
voir des gens nus quand je vois cette
passivité et gênante parce qu'elle a
souvent une connotation sexuelle pour
planter la preuve c'est qu'il ya plein
de gens qui se font harceler maintenant
qu'ils font ça sans arrière pensée et à
des gens avec des smartphones qui les
prennent en photo qui se servent des
faudrait les faire changer non des
smartphones
pour les faire chanter donc je pense que
c'est dangereux et qu'il ne faut pas
qu'ils aient plus d'espacé
non non mais c'est ridicule de dire ça
c'est encore une baisse à milan chez moi
toi conte avec ta petite fille
à fille et tuba mardi avec moi que mes
parents y aller quand j'étais jeune ça
m'a dérangé
on y avons nature et dans la famille
venez vous
allez faire tes courses
la deuxième étoile on était très connu
dans les calanques de marseille ou dans
les alpes de haute provence on était
très ému qui va faire l'état compagnies
renommées en nature il est allé ça vous
gêne
je t'assure ah oui y'a pas une couille
dans le potage
[Applaudissements]
oui on entre en
belgique mais justement en france est la
première destination mondiale du
tourisme c'est quoi le cas du 10 mai la
france mais je lis et 6
millions de huit
signatures y soit la moitié moins moi je
pourrais pas suivi of beauty matt de
gilles vaudois eroglu tu vois la jsk ça
me casse la tête
déjà moi c'est bien quand elle est ma
façon tu vois voilà nom du frère
fofana sud pendant le ramadan je devrai
alors c'est pendant le match ça vous
gênerait thomas personnes femmes déjà
dénudée non mais ça me sidère de 90
c'est relou c'est relou seroul ou alors
franchement accord quand j'étais déjà
fait draguer tout paramétrer salaires
non mais sans déconner non mais je n'ai
pas de jugement de valeur mais jamais
été séance air de naturisme mou du genou
est alors difficile d'en dénaturer
benhaim j'aurais bien la voir non mais
moi je suis trop à rien oui je suis
pudique ouais c'est vrai mais vous
n'êtes pas publics cheryl un non mais
moi c'est ronnie fond de toute cette
journée du tout en train de jouer au
tennis avec les couilles c'est très
agréable le clown entreriez plus
facilement votre zigonet que vos pieds
non je me trompe non non non il a
montrées la télévision alors comme tu
cette voiture
je vais dire
mais c'est vrai que parfois c'est mal
indiquées et on peut se retrouver sur un
endroit on se retrouve avec un jour avec
soi rien écouter tranquillement quand
même faire un pique nique à la glace y
retrouve il se tait que la glacière
équilibre et puis là tu te retrouves non
mais c'est ben
vrai tout est balisé il y aura permis
non prenez l'escalier partie des fois je
me suis toujours posé la question fait
qu'il est en brouille avec un gars
assez commun
non mais c'est quoi ça a été très
rigolo c'est toujours la nuit tu vois tu
as des dégâts qui d el khaoua pas de
petawawa les bon voila voila tu vas
mettre un peu ce lit tu mets quelque
chose tu vois ce en découle est ce que
vous savez par exemple il ya des îles
dans les baléares où ça ou c'est que les
gens se mélangent que si on allait les
îles corones
il ya des chansons qui sont naturistes
en masse des gens qui
aillent est devant qu'est-ce qu'il ya
qu'il voulait dire quelque chose non
pour défendre un peu le truc quand même
parce qu'il y en a il y en a des
millions en france c'est vrai que c'est
une philosophie de vie semi liberté pour
eux ils se voient pas habiller ces gens
là donc en fait faut aussi les accepter
il kiffe leur truc après a demandé plus
que 7000 m² je pense que ça va durer 7
me mais le
coup n'est
pas parfois on n'est pas au courant
parce que moi quand je t'ai vu canoë
quand j'ai dix ans et que je me retrouve
à tomber et à me faire remonter par un
monsieur bah ouais
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué quand
j'ai bien sûr mais batman que ses
adhérents mais je comprends donnez moi
je suis du rafting
il faut trouver nez à nez avec une yole
mais c'est vrai non mais franchement
c'est pas possible schilb ernesto café
du naturisme vraiment je te lis temps
frais avec fatou elle ne voudrait pas ah
bah voilà mais elle pourrait être
habillé
ne dit qu'ils seraient jaloux qu'on la
voit tout nu un mois il en est hors de
question
la juriste
gaz et en nature
ivry la carrière de naturistes vous
savez il ya des grades de naturisme
rigoler quoi quand vous quand vous allez
au supermarché vous sortez vous êtes
réputé on vous garde confiance pour
l'année date
mais je n'aimerais pas d'eau ni les
professionnels
à un classement disons que j'étais
réputé quoi
rigoler il y avait des élections maturi
c'était pas mal classés avec des
meilleurs en camping j'avais ma place
mais l'élection de miss
d'argent
en
fait à une vidéo ou photo we were oui
camping sauvage naturiste j'ai tout
faire
d'être sympa pour les